Labor Day is upon us millions of
Americans are trying to squeeze out the
last moments of Summer Fun Some are
hitting the road to get at a Dodge and
enjoy that nice long holiday weekend or
you're one of the Unlucky ones who has
to navigate one of Joe Biden's hellish
airports
I wish you good luck the FAA is warning
it's going to be one of the busiest
holiday weekends of the year more than 3
000 flights delayed already today and
the people are acting as insane as ever
a guy freaking out over the overhead
storage bin and getting himself kicked
off a flight he was repeatedly
complaining about another dude stashing
too many bags in his overhead bin space
and who can forget the ax wielding pilot
went berserk on a parking gate arm
giving it a good 23 whacks until cops
arrested him Transportation secretary
Pete butterjudge trying to act like he's
on top of all the flight chaos but just
wound up blaming the usual suspects for
his incompetence listen not only are we
seeing the system rebound from the worst
effects of covid but we're seeing things
come more in line with what we would
have regarded as normal now that doesn't
mean that the system was immune from
some tough travel days this year and
this summer most of the rough days that
we did see this year had to do with
storms that affected hubs which then had
cascading effects but we all know how
hard hat Pete not really focused on
solving Americans flight problems it's
because he's too busy working on
Transportation equity
who the judge is appointing a group of
leading experts to advise them how all
cars should be phased out because they
could cause climate change and promote
racism
okay Judge Jeanine uh well mayor Pete uh
hard hat Pete as we like to call him
does he seem to concerned to you about
the worst travel day of the year no his
main concern right now is making sure
that we don't find out about his own
private flights because he doesn't take
the planes that we're all taking and by
the way here is a study here if
emissions of greenhouse gases were
stopped with the climate return to the
conditions of 200 years ago the answer
is no I'll put that away now
Transportation Equity Transportation
Equity I looked it up do you know what
it is I don't okay it seeks fairness in
mobility and accessibility to meet the
needs of all community members okay so
that means you've got to be accessible
to everybody I think most roads are and
I think most buildings are and most
sidewalks most courthouses most
department stores are so then I went to
the next definition now they say cars
are bad
so I said to myself self why are cars
bad and according to them the invention
of the automobile uh created government
housing opportunities because they gave
loans to White veterans which led to the
creation of suburban housing and created
white flight to the suburbs to achieve
the American dream none of this makes
any sense to me here's the bottom line
people to judge ought to learn how to
run the Department of Transportation
stop blaming covid and equity and all
this other nonsense and stop paying
people a hundred dollars you missed your
flight no go to the underlying reason
and the reason people are nuts and I've
I've been flying most weekends for the
past few months people are nuts they
don't want you in their bin above their
seat and they don't want you in their
area you know using the bathroom people
are crazy it's not your bin area though
that area could belong to anybody at
least that's what the flight attendants
told me Richard Richard while we have
you here
what is transportation Equity look I I'm
not sure here here it's right here I
have had it uh I could give some
historical context to what the judge is
talking about and she's talking about
the creation of the GI bill and when the
GI bill was created black veterans were
not allowed to apply for the GI bill
they weren't allowed to get loans they
had to live in Redline communities as a
result of that they weren't able to
benefit from other programs at other
parts of our community were able to
benefit from now that being said I don't
think that has any impact of what's
happening with flight delays right I
think that you I think that the
translation secretary has enough people
that work at the department translation
to focus on that and also deal with
what's happening with flights uh a
couple weeks ago I visited the control
tower at DCA Reagan National Airport
um and I got a chance to talk to some
air traffic controllers about what's
actually the issue and what they will
tell you is we're short staffed and you
can't just hire an air traffic
controller today and expect them to go
until that planes take off and land
tomorrow it takes months and months of
training to get these people prepared to
control planes the same goes for Pilots
we have a shortage in Pilots you can't I
don't want anybody flying by plane that
got a pilot license yesterday you need
some training to this so to get to the
point where we are where our flights can
get back to running in normal we have to
train staff and we have to get them in
the right places and with that being
said when you see what these folks do
every day they are unsung heroes the
fact that out of the entire world
America has the safest Aviation system
and it's all because of those folks
sitting in the air traffic control
towers that you never hear of you never
speak to them but they're the folks that
keep your planes going landing and they
owe us that we owe them a dead of
gratitude so was that terrifying to see
or I mean
more confidence or less it was
terrifying to see because how fast
they're moving but it was also
remarkable to see how fast they were
moving and how many planes they were
moving at the same time landing and
taking off absolutely same time it was
remarkable Charlie we've had Personnel
issues in the flight industry since the
pandemic's been over this is almost
three years now mayor Pete's been in
charge for a while has he done anything
to maybe speed up the process of the
hiring and the training no of course not
because they're so confused he's so
focused on uh Transportation Equity
whatever that is uh and they're still
blaming covid and they're still blaming
uh global warming I guess and racism
obviously
um and uh no and this is why you you
literally cannot let these people be in
charge anything that is serious anything
that actually has consequences that that
people that people can get hurt uh doing
uh or not doing
um you can't let them because their
focus is not on a successful Mission
look what they're doing to the military
the the success they have no concept of
what a successful mission is they're
just trying to like fill these boxes and
play this weird political game of
Charades that has absolutely nothing to
do with what the the airline is there to
do for us I mean he wants to be a
diversity officer mayor Pete and if he
wants to do that he can do that but
maybe Transportation secretary not his
thing well I think he's going to solve
it because he has a new committee he has
revived for uh the called the advisory
committee on Transportation Equity
President Obama this is a Obama era uh
project so again Obama's third term they
didn't fix it during the Obama
Administration they did not Donald Trump
got rid of it completely waste of time
but there are 24 new members on this and
one of the women who is a spatial policy
scholar that we need 24 committee
members to solve this problem apparently
she is saying that all cars are bad and
that we need to create streets that are
inclusive of people
not cars it's like okay so you've a made
cars way too expensive for Americans to
own regular cars used cars are still
expensive then you want to force them to
buy electric cars which nobody can
afford that these companies are going to
go bankrupt making and now you're saying
we just should get rid of cars
completely so that people have no
Freedom or autonomy to go travel about
the country so I'm glad that we're our
taxpayer dollars are being used for a
new committee and I'm sure that he will
be spending his time with these 24
people and they will just fix it right
away it sounds like everything will be
justified walks is that what she wants
apparently yes but it kind of defeats
the purpose the whole purpose of having
a street is for cars right and like one
of the first things you teach your
children is don't walk in the street yes
because that's where the car to make a
street more inclusive of yeah but there
could be buses on that street there
could be okay even more more important
that you don't make it inclusive of
humans
walkable neighbors I know what it is I
like bike paths yeah right it's bike
paths it's always the bike paths Richard
cars equal Freedom hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else